The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN OPPENHEIM:
Throughout these lectures,
we have been considering the
analysis and the implementation
of discrete time linear
shift invariant systems,
or what we've been referring
to as digital filters.
In this lecture, I
would like to begin
the discussion of the
design of digital filters.
Now the rationale
for digital filters
is exactly the same as
it is for analog filters.
In particular, we have taken
advantage several times
of the important
property of linear shift
in variance systems that complex
exponentials are eigenfunctions
of this class of systems.
In other words, then with a
complex exponential input,
the output is a
complex exponential
of the same complex frequency
multiplied by the system
function H v to the j omega.
Or equivalently, with
a sinusoidal input,
the output is
likewise sinusoidal
with the same frequency but
with a change in amplitude
and with a change in phase.
Now what this property of
linear shift invariant systems
permits us to consider
is the separation
of signals that have been
added when these signals occupy
different frequency bands.
Specifically, we can
consider a signal composed
of the sum of two signals,
one of which we want,
the other of which
we don't want,
or we would like to suppress.
And if those two signals are
in different frequency bands--
in other words, their spectra
occupy different segments
of the frequency axis, then we
can choose the system function
for the linear shift
invariant system
so that it is unity in
the band of frequencies
that we want to keep and at
0 in the band of frequencies
that we want to reject.
That of course, is
exactly the same notion
as we have in continuous time
or analog systems or filters.
So for example, if we
had a signal, which
was the sum of two components,
one of which was low frequency,
and that we wanted to keep,
and the other of which
was high frequency and
that we wanted to suppress,
then we can consider
extracting the wanted signal
with a system whose
frequency response ideally
is unity at the
low frequency end
and at zero at the
high frequency end,
or after some cutoff frequency,
which I've denoted by omega sub
P.
So this then is
one type of filter
and one class of
filtering problems,
generally, what we
would refer to as
frequency selective filters.
We've illustrated that
here with the example
of a low-pass filter.
But of course there are
other kinds of frequency
selective filters--
for example,
high-pass, band-pass,
band-stop, multiple
band filters, et cetera.
Furthermore, the
filtering problem,
both digital and
analog, is of course,
not restricted to just simply
frequency selective filters.
We can think of problems-- we
can talk about a wide variety
of problems, in fact--
where the frequency
characteristics
that are desired are not
piecewise constant as they
are in the frequency
selective filter case,
but might be non-piecewise
constant such as, for example,
with the case of a
differentiator, in which case
the desired frequency
characteristic is
in fact, linear with frequency,
or in the inverse filtering
problem where the desired
frequency characteristic is
in general of a somewhat
arbitrary shape.
And so in this
more general sense,
the filtering problem
can be thought
of in terms of
the implementation
of a linear shift
invariant system
with a specified frequency
response characteristic
that we wish to achieve.
To carry out the discussion,
all the discussion that
will be carrying out today
and in fact throughout most
of these lectures on
digital filter design,
I'll relate primarily to
frequency selective filters
and in fact, to
low-pass filters,
although it's important to keep
in mind that the digital filter
problem, the digital
filter design problem,
is not restricted to just
that class of filters.
Well, for the case of an
ideal low-pass filter,
or a low-pass filter, this
is the desired frequency
characteristic.
And so what's the problem?
Well, we have seen in
the last several lectures
that for the implementation
of digital filters,
it's particularly convenient to
have a filter or a system whose
system function is representable
as a rational function of z,
or equivalently whose
input-output characteristic
can be related by means of a
linear constant coefficient
difference equation.
A linear constant coefficient
difference equation,
or a rational system
function, can't
achieve exactly an ideal
low-pass filter characteristic
as we have here, and in
general can't achieve
any ideal frequency
selective characteristic
where the transition
from one band to another
is as abrupt as we would
like it to be ideally.
So in fact, what's
required is to approximate
this ideal frequency
characteristic,
and the approximation
of the ideal frequency
characteristic, and the
design of a rational transfer
function to implement
that approximation
is what the digital filter
design problem is about.
So whereas we talk ideally
about a filter characteristic,
as I've indicated
here, in fact, we
have to allow some deviation
from this ideal characteristic
so that we would permit as an
example a frequency response,
rather than being
unity in the passband,
to deviate from
unity by some amount.
And let's designate that
by say, delta sub P,
denoting a passband deviation.
So that in fact where
we might specify
is a filter which
in the passband,
in the band of frequencies
that we wish to pass,
rather than being
exactly unity, is
constrained in the
interval between unity
and 1 minus delta sub P.
Similarly, we might permit
the frequency characteristics,
rather than requiring them to be
exactly 0 in a stopband region.
We might permit the frequency
characteristic to deviate
from 0 by some amount which
we can denote as delta sub
S, which is the stopband
deviation, in which case
we would ask that the filter
fall between 0 and delta sub
S, that is that the filter
that we actually design
be restricted to
this frequency range.
And finally recognizing
that in reality we
can't achieve a discontinuity in
the frequency response as sharp
as I've indicated here,
we would permit also
a transition region.
That is, we would permit
a region, after which
the frequency characteristic
must be below delta sub S,
and before which the
frequency characteristic must
be between 1 and 1
minus delta sub P,
but allowing a region for
it to make the transition
from the passband
to the stopband.
So these are the kinds of
specifications on a filter.
And a typical kind of
characteristic then
that might result
is a filter perhaps
that ripples between
these limits 1 and 1
minus delta sub P
in the passband,
and then makes the transition
into a stopband region
and perhaps wiggles around
in the stopband region,
sometimes perhaps touching
the limits and sometimes not.
So what the digital filter
design problem is then,
is given a set of
specifications on the filter,
recognizing that we can
implement an ideal filter,
but in fact allowing
some deviation
from the ideal filter.
The digital filter
design problem
is then to design a rational
transfer function, which
approximates in some sense,
this ideal filter maintaining
the specifications of passband
and stopband deviation
that we've imposed
on the problem.
Now, there are several
classes of design techniques
that we can consider.
The first class of
design techniques,
which in fact, we won't
be talking much about,
is the class that I've referred
to as analytical design
techniques.
Basically what I mean by that
are design techniques that
permit the approximation of the
ideal frequency characteristic.
The approximation is carried out
through an analytical procedure
and results in a closed
form transfer function.
That in fact is a
very common class
of techniques for continuous
time or analog filter design.
And that leads us to the second
class of design techniques,
namely the class of
design techniques
that I refer to as
mapping continuous time
to discrete time.
Well, why in the world
would we ever want a map
from continuous time
to discrete time?
Well, the reason, very
simply, is that a lot of work.
And a lot of results have
developed for the design
of continuous time filters.
And in fact, a lot
of these procedures
are analytical procedures.
They lead to
analytical, or they lead
to closed form designs and
their analytical procedures that
can be used.
Now, if it's possible
to map those designs
to digital designs, then
in fact, that's something
we should do simply
to take advantage
of the kinds of results that
have been worked out previously
in the design of analog filters.
An important point
to keep in mind,
however, is that we don't
mean by this approximating
an analog filter with
a digital filter.
That's not the objective, that's
a point that we've stressed
throughout these lectures.
Our objective is not to
approximate an analog filter
with a digital filter.
But if in fact, we can
utilize analog designs
in designing digital
filters, then that's
something we should do.
And in fact, there
are some procedures
that allow us to do this
that are very successful.
The third class of
design techniques
are what are referred
to as algorithmic
or computer-aided
design techniques.
And the basic idea
here is that there
are a variety of
algorithmic procedures,
iterative procedures that we
can go through to carry out
the digital filter design.
And we'll see a brief
discussion of a number of these
in the next several lectures,
both for infinite impulse
response filters and for finite
impulse response filters.
Now, in fact on the issue
of infinite impulse response
and finite impulse
response, it turns out
that it's convenient
to separate the design
issues for infinite
impulse response
and for finite impulse
response filters.
There are techniques for
the finite impulse response
case that are not applicable to
the infinite impulse response
case, and vice versa.
And consequently, as we talk
about digital filter design
techniques, we'll
be talking first
about the design of
infinite impulse response,
or what we alternatively
refer to as
recursive digital
filters, and then we'll
talk separately about
some design procedures
for finite impulse response or
non-recursive digital filters.
So for this lecture, and
in fact for this lecture
and the next lecture, and in
fact for this and the next two
lectures, we'll be
focusing entirely
on the design of
infinite impulse response
digital filters.
And in the lecture
following that,
we'll consider some design
procedures for finite impulse
response filters.
All right, well, the
first class of procedures,
design techniques that
I'd like to discuss,
are ones related to mapping
from continuous time
to discrete time--
that is, taking analog
filter design techniques
and utilizing them for the
design of digital filters.
So the procedure
basically is that we're
mapping from continuous
time to discrete time.
We have a continuous time
system function, H sub a of S,
which is the Laplace transform
of the impulse response,
H sub a of T, the H
standing for analog.
And we'd like to map that
to a digital filter transfer
function, H of z,
or equivalently
map the impulse response
to a digital filter unit
sample response, H of n.
And we'd like to do this,
of course, in such a way
that if this was a good filter
in the analog domain, then
this will be a good filter
in the digital domain.
Well, of course in designing
digital filters by implementing
and mapping of the type
that we're talking about,
there are some
obvious restrictions
that we would like
to impose, one
of which is that we would like
the behavior of H sub a of S,
the analog system
function, on the j omega
axis to map to a corresponding
behavior on the unit circle.
The point, of course,
is that an analog system
function or an analog filter, an
analog frequency response, when
we talk about the
frequency response,
we're looking in the
s-plane on the j omega axis.
And for the digital
filter, it is the behavior
of the system function
on the unit circle
that dictates what the
frequency response is like.
If the analog filter has a
good frequency response--
in other words, it has a good
behavior on the j omega axis--
that's what we would
like to have mapped over
to a good behavior in the
z-plane on the unit circle.
So this then is
the first condition
that we would like to impose.
And a second condition that
it's reasonable to impose
is that a stable
analog system function
mapped to a stable
digital system function.
In other words, we'd
like to be confident
that our design
procedure is such
that if we had a
good analog filter
and it was stable, that
when we were all done,
we would end up with a good
digital filter that was also
stable.
So these, then, are two
of the conditions that
are basic to any
design procedure that
maps from continuous
time to discrete time.
Well, there are a number of
procedures that are available.
One of the first
that tends to come
to mind when you think of
mapping a continuous time
filter to a discrete
time filter is
to approximate in
some sense, let's
say the differential equation
for the analog filter,
by simply replacing the
derivatives by differences.
So the first method that
I'd like to talk about
is a method which corresponds
to going from the analog filter
to the digital filter
by mapping differentials
in the analog domain
to differences
in the digital domain.
And let me tell you in
advance that what we'll see,
in fact, is that although
this is intuitively
one of the first methods
that tends to come to mind,
that in fact, it is not a
particularly good method
in terms of the basic
guidelines that we've set down.
But let's go through
the method anyway.
Here we have an analog system
function, H sub a of S.
And the corresponding
differential equation,
the filter then is described in
terms of a linear combination
of derivatives of the output
equal to a linear combination
of derivatives of the input.
Now we want to convert
this in some way
to a difference equation.
And so we can consider replacing
y sub a of t by y of n,
y of n, of course is the
output of the digital filter,
in such a way that the
derivative, a first derivative
sampled at t equal
to n times T gets
replaced by the first
difference of the output
of the digital filter.
Where the first
difference I'm defining
as the first forward difference.
That is, y of n plus 1
minus y of n divided by T.
So the idea here is
basically to say, well
look, I can generate
a difference
equation from this
differential equation
by replacing the
derivatives by differences--
in the particular case
I'm talking about,
by forward differences.
And what will result is
a difference equation,
and consequently what also
results is a digital filter.
Incidentally, I'm
talking about this here
for the case of forward
differences in the text
to see the contrast.
We talk about a
similar procedure,
but with the use of backward
differences rather than
forward differences.
All right, well let's see,
in fact, what happens then.
We want to replace
a first derivative
by a first forward difference.
More generally,
what we would want
to replace a k-th derivative by
is the k-th forward difference,
where the k-th
forward difference
is defined iteratively.
In other words, the k-th
forward difference of y of n
is the first forward
difference of the k
minus first forward
difference of y of n.
Simply the k-th
forward difference
to correspond to
the k-th derivative
is the first difference
implemented over and over
and over again, k times.
So what results then by
making this substitution,
is that the differential
equation that we had,
which was a linear
combination of the derivatives
of y of t equal to a linear
of x of t, that's replaced by
the same linear combination
of the k-th difference of y of
n equal to the corresponding
linear combination of the
k-th differences of x of n.
And this then is a
difference equation,
because of the fact that each
of these differences, each
of these four differences, or
the k-th forward difference,
involves differences of y of n.
That is why even
plus 1 minus y of n
So this is a difference equation
derived from the differential
equation by replacing
the k-th derivative
by the k-th forward difference.
Well let's see what this
means in terms of the mapping
from the s-plane to the z-plane.
First of all, let me remind
you that in the continuous time
domain, the Laplace transform
of the derivative of a time
function is equal to s times the
Laplace transform of the time
function.
That is, the operation of
differentiation in the Laplace
transform domain gets carried
over to a multiplication by s.
Similarly, we can look
at the z transform
of the first difference,
the z transform
y of n plus 1 minus y
of n divided by T, simply by
applying the properties of z
transforms, results
in z minus 1 divided
by T times the z
transform of y of n.
So the operation of taking the
first difference corresponds
to multiplying the z transform
by z minus 1 divided by T.
So in the continuous
time domain,
the derivative corresponded
to multiplication by s.
In the z transform
domain, first differencing
corresponded to
multiplication by z minus 1
divided by T. And it's
straightforward to show
that, in fact, the k-th
forward difference corresponds
to multiplying by z
minus 1 over t to the k.
And we know that the k-th
derivative corresponds
to multiplication by s to the k.
So if you track that through,
put that into the difference
equation, and obtain
the system function
for the digital
system, and compare it
with the system function for
the analog system, what you see
resulting is that the operation
of replacing differentials
by differences corresponds
to obtaining the transfer
function of the digital
filter from the transfer
function of the analog
filter by the substitution
s equal to z minus
1 divided by T.
So it's basically
a mapping then,
S being replaced by
z minus 1 over T,
or equivalently, z is
equal to 1 plus s times T.
First point then is that
this technique in fact
corresponds to a mapping from
the s-plane to the z-plane,
with s replaced by
a function of z.
Well, let's see what
this mapping is, in fact,
and decide whether it satisfies
the objectives that we
set down before.
Here is a picture
of the s-plane,
and here's the j omega axis.
Below we have the z-plane,
the imaginary axis, real axis,
and the unit circle.
And the first question
is, what does the j omega
axis in the s-plane
map to in the z-plane?
Well, we substitute
s equals j omega,
so that z is equal to
1 plus j omega times T.
Consequently, the j
omega axis in the s-plane
for this particular method maps
to this line in the z-plane.
Well, is that good?
No, it's not good,
because it says
that if we saw a good filter as
we ran up and down this axis,
we would see a good filter as
we run up and down this line.
However, where we are interested
in the filter characteristics
ending up are on
the unit circle,
which in fact, are only
close to this line when
we're in the vicinity
of z equal to 1.
So in fact, the first
condition that we wanted
isn't satisfied, namely
the j omega axis does not
get mapped to the unit circle.
Furthermore, stable analog
filters do not necessarily
map to stable digital filters.
For example, if we had a pole,
let's say in the s-plane there,
then it would fall in the
z-plane, let's say there.
Well, that's all right.
That's a stable pole,
stable analog filter mapping
to a stable digital filter.
However, here's an even
more stable analog filter.
And if this pole is negative
enough, then in fact,
it falls outside the unit
circle in the z-plane,
and consequently the digital
filter will be unstable.
That incidentally is
a well-known property
in numerical analysis
of forward differences--
that is, the notion that forward
differences are unstable.
And this is one
way of seeing that
by interpreting it
in terms of a mapping
from the s-plane to the z-plane.
We know incidentally that at
least in an intuitive sense,
it's reasonable to imagine
that if we pick samples
of a continuous time signal
close enough together, that
at least intuitively
we ought to be
able to approximate a
derivative by a difference.
And in fact, that fits in
with the kinds of things
that we've been seeing here
in the following sense.
If we very highly oversample
the signal, much higher
than the Nyquist
rate, then in fact,
the portion of the z-plane
where the signal spectrum falls
is the portion of the z-plane
around in the vicinity of z
equal to 1.
And you can see
that in that case,
that portion of
the unit circle is
pretty close to
this line which was
the mapping from the j
omega axis into the z-plane.
And so consequently, if we
oversample rather extensively,
then we can, in fact, map,
more or less, our analog
filter to a digital filter.
But in fact, in the
more usual case,
the digital signal spectrum
occupies the entire unit
circle.
And clearly away from
the regions equals 1,
the unit circle deviates
rather dramatically
from this vertical line.
All right, so this is a
method then of filter design,
which didn't satisfy either
one of our initial guidelines.
Namely, it didn't map the j
omega axis to the unit circle.
And also, it didn't map
a stable analog filter
to a stable digital filter.
Well, let's go on to a second
method, which is better
in both of those respects.
And this is a method
that is commonly
referred to as the method
of impulse invariance.
And again, it's a filter
design method, which
intuitively is very reasonable.
The basic idea of
impulse invariance
is to convert an analog
filter to a digital filter,
simply by choosing
the unit sample
response of the
digital filter to be
equally spaced
samples of the impulse
response of the analog filter.
So the unit sample
response h of n
is chosen to be equally
spaced samples, samples spaced
by T, equally spaced samples of
the analog or continuous time
filter.
Well, in at least one sense,
we can see that this certainly
leads to a good filter.
And that is, if we had
a continuous time analog
filter that had good impulse
response characteristics,
then those good impulse
response characteristics
would be carried over to the
digital filter unit sample
response.
For example, if we were
interested in a filter
with very low ringing or
very short impulse response,
then if we had an analog filter
with those characteristics,
then the digital filter would
likewise have good impulse
response characteristics.
However we've been phrasing
most of our discussion
in terms of frequency
response characteristics,
we know from the
discussion of sampling
that we had a number of lectures
ago that periodic sampling
of this type results
in a frequency response
for the digital system,
which is basically
an aliased version
of the frequency
response for the analog system.
That is, the digital frequency
response is given by the sum
that I've indicated
here, which consists
of scaled replicas
of the Fourier
transform of the analog filter,
repeated over and over again
with a spacing in
little omega of 2 pi.
Well, let's take a look at
that in a little more detail.
Here we have the analog
frequency response.
And let's say that
we're considering
this for the case of a
low-pass filter, which
is what we've tended to
focus on in this lecture.
So that if we had an
analog low-pass filter,
cutoff frequency between minus
omega sub a and plus omega sub
a, then in forming the digital
filter frequency response,
we first want to form h sub
a of j omega divided by T,
and then shift that in omega
by integer multiples of 2 pi
and add up those results.
So the first step
is the scaling,
basically replacing Omega
by omega divided by T,
in which case plotted
as a function of omega,
the cutoff frequency is
then omega sub a T and minus
omega sub a T, so that this
step results in a linear scaling
of the frequency
axis so that Omega
is replaced by
omega divided by T.
The second step then
is to add together
replicas of this analog
frequency response separated
in omega by integer
multiples of 2 pi.
And that's what
I've indicated here.
Of course, this periodically
repeats over and over again,
but I've sketched it just
from minus 2 pi to plus 2 pi.
We have the factor 1 over T
out in front for the amplitude.
But an important
aspect of this is
that we have in going from
the analog frequency variable
to the digital frequency
variable, a linear scaling
in the frequency axis.
That doesn't show
up particularly
for a piecewise constant
frequency characteristic
as I have here.
But generally, if I had
some complicated shape, then
when I convert to h sub
a of j omega over T,
that basic shape
will be preserved.
And it will only be
distorted by a linear scaling
in the frequency axis.
And that is an
important advantage
of the technique of
impulse invariance.
Now there are some
problems, one in particular.
And this is the major problem.
And that is that as
I've drawn this example,
we've considered an analog
filter whose frequency response
is strictly bandlimited.
And so of course there is
no aliasing that results.
But more generally, the kind
of frequency characteristic
that we would have would
look perhaps like this,
as an approximation, admittedly
a somewhat crude approximation,
to this ideal low-pass filter.
In which case, as we
add up the replicas
of the scaled frequency
response, then we in general
will have interference
or aliasing
between different
terms in this sum.
So that in that case, while we
start with an analog frequency
characteristic that's desirable,
the resulting digital frequency
characteristic will
be distorted somewhat
because of the
aliasing that results
due to the separate terms that
are added together in this sum.
And one of the important aspects
of implementing an impulse
invariant filter
design, then, is
to in some way account
for and hopefully
minimize the effect
of this aliasing.
All right, so with the
impulse invariant method,
one of the important advantages
of impulse invariance
is the fact that it tends
to preserve good time domain
characteristics.
That is, the impulse response
characteristics were preserved.
And also, it provides
a linear scaling
from analog frequency
to digital frequency
so that if we had an analog
filter with a very complicated
frequency response,
then we could
be assured that the
corresponding digital filter
except for aliasing would
have that same shape,
but only with a linear
scaling of the frequency axis.
It should be pointed
out incidentally
that impulse invariance
doesn't imply step invariance,
and you'll see this
in the problems
that you work through
the study guide.
Impulse invariance does not
imply step invariance so
that in fact, if it was the
step response characteristics
that we wanted to preserve,
then the technique here
isn't what we would use.
We would use a
modified technique,
which would be not impulse
invariance, but step
invariance.
Well, let's finally look
at what impulse invariance
means in terms of a mapping
from the s-plane to the z-plane.
Let's look at it in a
slightly different way
than we've looked at it here.
And we can do that by expressing
the analog system function
in a partial fraction expansion,
in terms of a sum of factors
of this form.
So we have residues A sub k,
poles s at s equals s of k,
and we're expressing
the system function
as a linear combination
of terms of this form.
If there are
multiple order poles,
this expression is
slightly more complicated.
And what I'm about to say can
be generalized to that case.
But let's consider it here just
for the case of simple poles,
so that the system
function in fact
can be expanded out in
the form that I have here.
All right, well, if this is
the analog system function,
then you should recall that
the analog impulse response--
that is, the inverse
Laplace transform of this--
is the sum of exponentials
with amplitudes
A sub k, the same
amplitudes as we
have here, and complex
exponentials e to s sub k.
And this should be a t,
not a T. That is time, t.
So this then is the form
of the impulse response,
which corresponds to
this system function.
And now the impulse
invariant method says,
replace this by a
unit sample response
for the digital filter,
which is obtained
by replacing t by
n times T. That is,
obtaining the unit sample
response of the digital filter
by sampling the impulse response
of the analog filter, in which
case we get the sum of
A sub k, E to s of k.
And now time, t, is
replaced by n times T.
A sampled unit step, a
sampled analog unit step,
results in a discrete
time unit step.
And so consequently,
the unit sample response
that we end up with is A
sub k, the same coefficients
as we had here, e to the
s sub k, n times T times
the unit step.
Well, we can write that in
a slightly different way.
We can write that as
the sum of A sub k,
and some factor, e to the
s sub k T is what it is.
Some factor raised to the n-th
power times the unit step.
And consequently we can
write down by inspection
the z transform or system
function that corresponds
to this unit sample response.
In particular, it is H of
z equal to the sum of A sub
k, times 1 minus 8, e the s
of k times T z to the minus 1,
that's simply by inspection
of this expression.
All right.
Well, so we started
with an analog system
function of this form, these
coefficients in these poles.
We ended up with a
digital system function
of this form, the same
coefficients, and poles
instead of at s sub k, as
they were in the analog case,
at e to the s sub k T.
So this says then that the
impulse invariant method
maps a pole in the s-plane
which was at s sub k, maps
it to a pole in the
z-plane at z equal
to e to the s sub
k, T. Well, does
that mean that impulse
invariance is basically
a method which maps
s to z according
to this transformation.
Well no, it doesn't do that.
What it does is it maps
the poles in the s-plane
to poles in the z-plane
according to this mapping.
The other thing
that it preserves
are these coefficients,
the coefficients A sub k,
that is the residues
of the poles.
So it maintains the
residues of the poles.
It maps the poles according
to z equals e to the st.
The 0s, by the way,
in general will not
come out to have
been mapped according
to the same mappings equals
e to the st. In other words,
if we had a 0 at s equals s
sub 0, as we'll see actually
in an example that we'll work
next time, the 0 in the z-plane
will not come out, will not come
out at z equals e to the s 0 T.
The poles are mapped
according to that mapping,
and the residues are preserved.
And that is essentially what
defines the impulse invariant
mapping.
Well, we had our two
initial guidelines.
One is that we want the
behavior on the j omega
axis to map to the behavior in
the digital domain on the unit
circle.
Does the impulse
invariant method do that?
Well, it does, except for
the effect of aliasing.
But basically, it is the
analog frequency response
that dictates what the
digital frequency response is.
And so in that sense,
impulse invariance
satisfies that objective.
The second question is
whether it maintains
the ability of the filter.
And the answer there
also is that it does,
so we can see that very easily.
In particular, if we have an
analog pole with a real part
sigma sub k, an
imaginary part omega sub
k, then the digital pole, the
pole of the digital filter,
maps to z sub k equal
to e to the s sub k T,
e to the j omega sub k T.
And the magnitude of this
is equal to of course, the
product of the magnitudes.
The magnitude of
this term is unity.
So all that we care about is
the magnitude of the sigma
sub k T. Well, if the
analog filter is stable,
sigma sub k is negative.
If sigma sub k is negative,
then either the sigma
sub k T has a
magnitude less than 1.
So consequently, if the real
part of s sub k is less than 0,
negative, then the
magnitude of z sub k,
the magnitude of the
pole is less than 1.
So this in fact is a digital
filter design technique that
has a number of advantages.
And in fact, it's a very
useful design technique.
It's one of the standard digital
filter design techniques.
In the next lecture,
I will briefly
present an example of an impulse
invariant design, just simply
to remind you actually
again of the fact
that aliasing is an issue,
number one, and number two,
that it maps poles according
to z equals z to the st,
but not 0s.
In fact, the 0s end
up someplace else.
And in addition in
that lecture, we'll
talk about another design
technique, which is likewise
one of the classical
digital filter design
methods, which is referred to
as the bilinear transformation.
And the lecture
following that then I
will show some examples
of some digital filter
designs, using both impulse
invariance and the bilinear
transformation to compare them.
Thank you.